what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar and today we're going to be
talking about the most overpowered Titan
related abilities in attack on Titan if
you want more attack insane content make
sure to smash that like button to let me
know if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell so you don't miss any
new a ot videos as usual there will be
manga spoilers you've been warned
so just to clarify don't take the order
of this list too seriously
they're all very different abilities
that serve different functions the
purpose of this list is just for me to
talk about some of the greatest and most
interesting powers an attack on Titan
that being said I did try to save some
of the most opie abilities for last
before we get into it I want to share
something with you that I'm really
excited about you guys all know I love
making videos on this channel but I
often have ideas for shorter more punchy
content that just doesn't fit on YouTube
that's why I was extremely excited when
I found out about aminos new stories
feature and how you're able to just
watch new videos about anime that I
hadn't seen anywhere else it was awesome
and I love that amino stories don't just
disappear like in other places you can
watch amino stories whenever you want so
I was happy to partner with amino to
create some of my very own stories like
this 5 facts about Blackbeard from one
piece of video that you can find only on
my amino profile click the link in the
description or independ youtube comment
or search for amino apps to download
amino find my stories by searching anime
uproar make sure to follow me and click
the bell to know when i'm posting new
videos just like youtube every time you
watch my videos you'll be supporting me
so if you like my videos this is a
simple free way to keep me creating
again click the link in the description
or independent youtube comment or just
search for amino apps to download amino
find my stories by searching anime
uproar follow me and watch 5 facts about
Blackbeard and just by doing that you'll
be supporting this channel and me don't
forget to tap the bell to turn on
notifications to never miss an upload
now without further ado let's jump into
it in number 10 we have the timeshifters
ability to access past and
possibly future memories usually Titan
users only get some occasional glimpses
into the memories of past users kind of
like how Porco got some access to Ymir's
memories after he inherited the JA titan
power however the royal blooded founding
titan users take this ability to the
next level they appeared to have perfect
access to memories of all past users as
rod Reese tells historia royal blooded
founding Titan users know everything
about this world and how it came to be
they gained the power of the Titans
along with the lost memories of our
world this means they can potentially
remember things all the way back to the
first filing Titan yamir fritz
I'm reading a book on mastery right now
and it said that mastering any skill is
a matter of experience and the founding
Titan has access to all the accumulated
experience of past founding Titan users
not only that but because of this
ability to pass on your memories to
future users you can become immortal in
a sense Aaron says to Armin that if
memories play a major role in forming
who a person is that means part of Armin
has become Beth told the previous user
of the colossal Titan in this way Eren
suggests that Berthold can still
influence Army's judgment in the present
this would apply even more to founding
Titan users who would have even clearer
access to past memories the first king
of the walls carl Fritz was even able to
pass on his will in the form of his
pacifist ideology to all future royal
blooded founding Titans in a way he
still lived through all of the phallic
tyne users who came after him
besides immortality there's also the
ability to see future memories that
we've seen air and Krueger used when he
mentioned Mikasa and Armin before they
were even born
Ehren Kruger seemed to get a glimpse
into Eren Yeager's memories perhaps this
is not limited to the attack titan and
royal blood and founding Titans could
always see future Titan user memories in
addition to past Titan user memories
perhaps it was because they could see
the future with clarity that they
believed that it closed off existence
within the walls was the best possible
choice perhaps the first chapter is
called two you two thousand years from
now because it was yamir or some other
Titan user who is connected to Aaron's
future memories by way of a Titan path a
lot of this stuff is still surrounded by
mister
but the potential to see so many past
and future memories and the ability to
be immortal in this way - is definitely
an interesting and opie ability in 9th
place we had the ability of regeneration
regeneration is one thing but the Titan
shifters an attack on Titan take it to a
whole other level
we know characters can regenerate arms
teeth eyes and so on they can even use
selective regeneration to regenerate
some parts of the body sooner than
others but one of the craziest examples
of regeneration was when thunder spears
completely destroyed rider's brain along
with most of his head apparently he
transferred over his consciousness
across his body's nervous system and
used his Titans brain to retain his
memories
so Titan users can even potentially
survive beheading with their memories
intact if they have a Titan brain to use
however this is not even the limit of a
Titan shifters ope regeneration
abilities seek is able to survive a
point-blank Thunder spear fuse that Levi
attaches to his body Levi was not
letting him fully heal and then Zeke
sets off the Thunder spear on top of
already being injured everything below
Zeke's chest is completely destroyed
however our Titan takes what remains of
Zeke and puts it in its body and he
manages to come out completely healed
thus even when Titan shifters are all
but dead there is a chance they could
regenerate if certain conditions are met
at this point it's starting to seem like
the only way a time-shifter can be
killed is by being eaten by another
Titan all other attempts tend to fail
due to their opie regenerative abilities
in a place we have Aaron's Titans
ability to enter berserk mode its anim
only for now but I had to include it
because of how opiate makes eren's Titan
who is already very strong to begin with
this form is characterized by glowing
blue eyes and fiery lava like veins it
appears to be something like the Avatar
state from Avatar The Last Airbender
when a nice Titan is overpowering eren's
Titan Eren loses consciousness and that
is when seemingly the attack Titan goes
berserk and acts on its own it wasn't
present in the manga in the manga and he
is simply a stronger fighter than Eren
she kicks the attack times facing she
turns makes it to the wall and starts
climbing but Mika sir cuts her down
however in the anime the attack line
enters
berserk mode after his face is kicked in
and Annie starts running towards the
wall in berserk mode eren's Titan
catches up to her and tackles her down
he destroys the female Titans face she
gets a kick on him and starts running up
the wall in fear clearly she's no longer
match for eren's Titan in this mode the
berserk Titan manages to grab her leg
while she's climbing and take it with
him he does all this while missing his
left arm it is only then that Mikasa
comes into play after the berserk mode
proved it can completely overpower a
nice killed Titan with one arm
keep in mind annie is a very skill type
user so the fact that an inexperienced
Eren could overpower her really speaks
to how opie this berserk mode is as I
said before II say gamma was involved
with the anime and he said before in an
interview that he told the enemy
creators how he would have done some
stuff differently if he could do it
again perhaps this mode will be used in
the manga in the future and the anime is
foreshadowing that we'll have to wait
and see however if the mode could make a
pretty inexperienced Terran this strong
imagine how strong it can make his
current Titan which also has access to
Warhammer Titan powers whether it turns
out to be anime on Lee or comes later in
the manga you cannot deny the fact that
this berserk mode is overpowered in
seventh place we have the jaw tines
ability to harden it's already sharp and
powerful claws and jaws I was amazed
when I first read chapter 104 and saw
Porco's Titan in action he combined his
speed he is the swiftest Titan after all
with these hardened claws and jaws to
seemingly outclass and experienced
Aaron's attack Titan not only that but
his claws and jaws can even cut through
the heart and crystal that Annie and
Tiber sister have surrounded themselves
in before this type of defense of
crystal was presented as indestructible
nothing could dented and yet Porco's
jaws and claws could slice through it it
is only after Micah's the steps in to
help that Aaron is able to use the jaw
tight as a nutcracker but before that
his abilities proved to be extremely
impressive and they made him more than a
match for eren's Titan in sixth place we
have the Warhammer Titans ability to use
hardening to create a wide variety of
weapons as with the jaw Titan the
Warhammer Titan gave eren's Titan a lot
of trouble even more trouble the
warhammer Titan uses its ability to
create a giant spike from the ground
that stabs and lifts the attack Titans
body she can also create smaller spikes
to trap him in place the Warhammer she
creates is so strong that she can break
through two of the attack tines heavily
heart and arms and its head like it was
nothing it appears like the Warhammer
Titan is about to finish Aeryn with this
hammer when we cuz that comes to the
rescue and yes she comes to rescue a lot
only for Aaron to be mean to her later
unforgivable but let's shelve our
indignation for now and continue the war
hammer Titan survives because the
Thunder Spears increase a crossbow
that's right a freaking crossbow and she
would have hit Aaron if Myka son didn't
pull him away in time the Warhammer
Titan can almost make any weapon you can
think of so we don't have time to go
through all of them here but it's enough
to know that Aaron uses the Warhammer
Titans powers for himself back within
the walls to hold his own against Marlys
military and their three Titans long
enough for Zeke to show up the Warhammer
Titan was the last of the ninth Titan
powers to be revealed and it was
definitely worth the wait because of
this opie ability in 5th place we have
the special acraman ability which
heightens and awakened Ackerman's
physical abilities to an extreme at this
point you might be thinking but wait
goes in I thought you said you were
listing the top 10 overpowered Titan
abilities the Ackerman's aren't Titans
well perhaps not but if you're caught up
to the manga you know that their
abilities come from Titans making them
Titan abilities the Ackerman clan is the
byproduct of Titan science as Aaron
explains when the LD and Empire was
fiddling around with the subjects of
yamir they accidentally created the
Ackerman's who maintained a human form
but in some cases can manifest the power
of the Titans not only that but the
Ackermann ability once awakened gives
the Ackermann the battle experience
accumulated by every past acraman by way
of a path just as Titans and subjects of
yamir are connected by a path so are
Ackerman's so it would seem that Mikasa
is accumulated battle experiences of
Levi Kenny and every past Ackerman along
with super-strength regenerating powers
and other Titan like abilities I don't
need to explain this one too much we've
seen Levi destroy Titan after Titan
in one-to-one combat the beasts timerlay
strongest warriors stood no chance
against him and as I've been saying
Mikasa always comes to the rescue
she's only able to rescue Eren from
strong opponents so often because she is
so opie but yeah I don't think I need to
go I'll commit to you guys how OPD
Ackerman's are so let's move on in 4th
place we have the robberies Titans huge
size and the heat that accompanies it
near the beginning of the series
everyone was shocked by the size of the
colossal Titan he dwarfed the other
Titans with his 60 meter height
he was the first Titan that showed up
that was taller than the 50 meter wall
well Rodriquez Titan is 2 times as big
the biggest Titan we've ever seen he is
120 meter height dwarfs that of the
colossal Titan the giant size makes rod
rhesus Titan even more physically
powerful than the god of destruction
himself which is another name for the
colossal Titan while the colossal tank
could only kick through one of the gates
of the walls [ __ ] believes that rod
rhesus Titan could just destroy the
walls themselves like the colossal Titan
except even more so because it's bigger
rod rhesus Titan is extremely hot it
produces a hot and deadly steam that
makes all the trees around it catch fire
although the Titan is eventually
defeated by a clever strategy it remains
the biggest and physically strongest
Titan we've seen and the amount of heat
that it gives off because of its giant
size makes it even more dangerous
NOP in third place we have the colossal
Titans explosion ability the user of the
colossal Titan power can control the
energy produced during his
transformation the transformation can
just create a wind blast or it can
create a giant destructive explosion
that looks like an atomic bomb
after bertolt uses this ability he
destroys everything in his area
including houses and many people later
Arman uses this ability to create a huge
explosion that destroys the Marlin naval
fleet it is totally possible that this
explosion ability could create even
bigger explosions if the user chose to
or if they trained enough to me this is
such an overpowered ability because you
can destroy anyone in your area if you
chose to everyone except the armored
Titan who does have resistance to this
ability even an acraman or Rod rhesus
giant Titan wouldn't stand much of a
chance
they were caught up in this explosion
and that's what makes it so Opie it's
like having a weapon of mass destruction
that you can carry around with you and
detonate at any time and it does no
damage to the user in second place we
have an ability that is associated with
the founding type I'm talking about its
ability to rewrite memories and reshape
the bodies of LD UNS we know that the
first can use this power to erase the
memories of the outside world in the LD
and population inside the walls minority
bloodlines weren't affected but the
subjects of yamir were because they're
connected by the same paths this can be
done on one-on-one basis - like when
Freda Ruiz to use the ability to erase
his story as memories of her after
meetings for a while we think it's just
memory manipulation but Tom's aver
points out that the founding Titan is
able to change the bodies of Ymir's
descendants the founding Titan can
change the composition of their bodies
so that they are immune to certain
diseases or even so that they can't have
kids which is what Zeke wants to do as
Tom points out and I quote we
descendants of yamir no matter where or
in what condition we find ourselves in
we are like one part of the founding
Titans body and quote Tom puts himself
in this category even though he's a
shifter which suggests that this power
when used to its full potential could be
used on other Titan shifters as well
thus if a fully functioning founding
Titan wanted to they could defeat any
subject of yamir even Titan shifters
like the colossal Titan by either
changing their memories so they want to
obey the founding Titan rather than
fight them or by changing their body's
composition so that they are unable to
fight anymore and finally in first place
we have the founding Titans ability to
perfectly control titans including the
tens of millions of colossal Titans that
are still in the walls while the ability
to rewrite the memories and reshape the
bodies of subjects of your MIR makes one
practically invincible against subjects
of yamir this ability to control
millions of colossal Titans and all of
the other Titans makes one invincible
against the whole world this ability can
supposedly be used to flatten the whole
earth it can destroy all of the nations
of the world no person Titan or nation
would stand a chance against this
ability
and that is why I guess the title of the
number one most overpowered ability in
attack on Titan and that is it for
today's video thank you so much for
watching if you enjoyed the video make
sure to smash that like button to let me
know if you haven't be sure to subscribe
for more attack on Titan videos on this
channel we have a whole attack on Titan
playlist that is constantly being
updated so make sure to check that out
let me know what other attack on Titan
videos you would like to see in the
comments and let me know what your
favorite ability in attack on Titan is a
big thank you goes out to our patrons
over on patreon who help make videos
like this one possible I especially want
to thank our pro hero tier patrons the
one and only Gilgamesh chubs is the man
and nothing about a fan and are the one
tier patrons the ones who stand atop all
clans baby Rey a 1750 P Steven Ingrid ah
a Lola not a Mattie Mac 239 and Michael
Calderon if you enjoy our work and it
gives you value you can support more of
it by going over to patreon calm and pro
and becoming a patron today for as
little as one dollar if you do so you'll
get your name featured in future videos
alongside these amazing people right
here and you'll even get access to our
private patron only discord so check out
patreon.com/crashcourse
[Music]